[Musik]
die bundesregierung hat angekündigt 100
milliarden euro in die ausstattung und
ausrüstung der bundeswehr zu investieren
bundeskanzler scholz erwägt sogar den
kauf eines raketenabwehrsystems für
deutschland sein vorbild israel und das
bekannteste raketenabwehrsystem der welt
er eigendorf
[Musik]
iron dome besteht aus drei komponenten
einerseits haben wir das radarsystem
dass die abgefeuerte rakete erkennt und
wir haben das kontrollzentrum wo die
kämpfer und kämpferinnen würden das gab
22 hat die welt verändert der kanzler
spricht von einer zeitenwende das nicht
nur eine floskel
wie sicher sitzt deutschlands ist
durchgehend brutalen angriffskriegen ins
zentrum der
geboren